it was a normal day in league of legends
drx faced off against ns in week two of
the lck
there were no surprises in champ select
until
this happened very much a gnar
uh pick looking like it's gonna come
through here laughing
here is yoshi because he locks into you
dear oh we're doing it all right
this wasn't supposed to happen for the
past
five years oodia has been absent in
korea and most other major regions
because
well he's an old champ that kind of
sucked
but for the last two weeks he's been
picked dozens
and dozens of times in the major regions
so
how did a bear man that runs around
slapping people become one of the
strongest picks in pro play
good question
[Music]
just before we get into this crazy story
of the bear man running on a rampage
i've got to remind you guys if you
haven't done so already
make sure you are subscribed to the
channel and also turn on notifications
so you don't miss a single video
that houdi pick didn't stay in korea for
long
soon we saw it in china running into the
lane in uniform he's been here before he
knows what this
feels like this is 2v3 it's suing a
winning it out
and before you know it there he is in
the lcs
lock-in finals the next drake is
spawning here in 30 seconds
blabbers got the dead man's plate with
the turbo kim tank the boy
runs fast flash bear
slap baby blabbers got him and alfari
is gone power of the rome with these two
but santorin is there
the deer is here and perks is running
away
team liquid turning back around horad's
in hot pursuit
a slap upside the head for a double kill
and udir is running wild on summoner's
rift in season 11.
just a few short months ago if you'd
have told people that ud was about to be
one of league's elite tier champions
they probably would have laughed at you
but here we are and i know that all of
you out there who are hard stuck silver
are probably getting gigger stomped
in solo queue by ud right now my
condolences
of course but let me explain exactly why
that is
as league has developed over the years
its champions have naturally become
more complex just look at a felios i had
to read his moves like
four times when he first came out to
understand exactly what he
actually does and now i can confidently
say
i'm still not sure so let's take a look
at the animal
spirit unlike literally every other
champion in the game udi has
no ultimate just four basic abilities
tiger stance empowers his auto attacks
turtle stance gives him a shield and
lifesteal phoenix stance creates flames
of aoe damage
and bear stance well that speeds him up
and stuns people for a moment when he
hits someone that's
it that is his whole kit he only has
one game plan run at people slap them
repeat you can seriously get the hang of
him in an aram on your lunch break
it's [ __ ] easy dude you have to
remember this champion was released
over 10 years ago he's probably older
than some league players at this point
in the time since the game has moved on
and ud
has felt like an old bear trying to
learn new tricks
the bears learn tricks in fact there was
a while where trick 2g
seemed to be the only big name who would
even touch ud
and his playstyle seemed to revolve
around running about and
just being annoying wow we look very
quick
oh we hit a ramp
newer champions with a lot of mobility
have traditionally been able to just
kite him out and then there's pro play
udi likes to run people down who are out
of position
and generally speaking pro players are
out of position
a lot less than your average player
basically his negatives
should outweigh his positives to the
point where pros
don't even bother with him but here we
are
with pro players picking you dear as
often as bronze players
are so what's going on well although udi
hasn't changed the game has changed
around him
season 11 brought the biggest items
overhaul the game has
ever seen some items were removed many
were added and it
seriously shook up the game people began
experimenting with the new items and
found that they
breathe life into old champions like ud
for example
iam germ explained why the new movement
speed items work
so well with ud um but then all the
movement speed items you could ever want
all the movement speed movement speed
items your heart could ever desire so
this is turbo chem tank
into boots into dead man's plate into a
force of nature for some even more
movement speed um and then from there
sometimes people are going to thornmail
i've seen people go randuin's omen to
get even more slowing and stuff
um it's so so annoying that turbo chem
tank is absolutely disgusting on udyr
getting that active movement speed
towards people
um it obviously helps when he's able to
slow or stun people and get the shield
uh it's just really really gross and you
can get absolutely so tanky
that you are just so annoying you're
able to do so much damage over time in
team fights pairing movement speed items
like
chem tank with runes such as phase rush
water walking and celerity
means that ud has gone from a casual
runner to
literally usain bolt
[Applause]
i mean this guy gets so fast uh if he
shows up on your screen you could be
uh at one corner screen he can be at the
other if he shows up on your screen he's
gonna run you down
even if you flash away a lot of the
times you're not gonna be safe if you're
not able to get over a wall if you're
not a champion that has a bunch of dash
and stuff
udyr's gonna run you down he's gonna get
you oh dear has spent
years watching other champions dash over
walls and
now he is fast enough to just run around
them
well sometimes chase after peanut and
the thumbs up comes in and then he jumps
back over the wall
[Laughter]
this is perfect lck
ud is also extremely good at clearing
his jungle partially
in thanks to a phoenix dance buff at the
end of last season
he doesn't even need a leash and this
can be invaluable
in pro play as prussian points out being
capable of clearing leashless is a
tremendous boon to laners
it hides your direct pathing and can
allow them to get priority in winning
matchups or to win neutrals
if enemy laners have to leash it lets
them set up waves so you can
gank directly after in the early game he
can face check with little cost to
himself by virtue of his high sustain
counter engage and disengage on top of
that
we're seeing supports like seraphine
building moonstone renewer and staff of
flowing water to turn
ud into even more of an unkillable race
car
udir is a fast clearing face-checking
speedy tank
and new items such as turbo cam tank and
force of nature have synergized
ridiculously well with his kit making
him even
faster and beefier basically his enemies
can dash
but they can't hide this perfect storm
of events means that udyr
hasn't really had to change his
playstyle he's doubled
down on it every champion has their
moment in the sun but
udes might be coming to an end sooner
than expected
with some nerfs that look set to knock
him off the top spot
most importantly how do the viewers the
community
feel about ud gracing these pro games
well
while some people probably do find him a
bit too simplistic to enjoy
a thread in support of him gained some
serious likes on reddit
scooch was quick to call out riot for
what he felt like was
inconsistency in who they choose to nerf
it feels like the balance team
chooses characters that they think are
cool and
don't [ __ ] touch them or chooses
characters that they think
deserve relevance and don't [ __ ]
touch them or keep them buffed or keep
them in the meta as much as they can
and then other characters like [ __ ] ass
udyr the second he becomes popular
they're like all right
buddy back into the dungeon with you
despite being a little bit of a meme
udir
is clearly loved by many he recently
topped a riot poll
for which old champions should be
reworked so you can expect to see
a whole new bear man by next year we can
sit here
and analyze items and game changes
all day but maybe the reason why udeer
is being picked so much in pro play
is a lot simpler it was pjosik who first
picked him
in the lck a few weeks back and really
started off this whole ud
craze and when invent global sat down
and asked him what
he thinks udi's biggest advantages he
said
the biggest advantage would be that udi
just simply makes opponents
angry it has an effect that can shake up
the opponent's mentalities
it's also really good for hit and run
with nerfs looming
and a rework planned for next year this
might be the last chance we get to enjoy
this iteration of udyr making his way
into professional play at the end of the
day perhaps we need to worry less about
understanding the intricacies of this
decade old champion
every now and again an old champion like
udyr
comes out of nowhere and just smashes
all the fancy new ones
so let's just enjoy him running around
and
slapping people to death while we still
can
i also feel like i could pull off in
terms of cosplay
i think i could pull off olaf you
probably could too olaf is like the
crazy berserker viking
dude with like a big red beard uh or
maybe graves
i've always thought if i ever do go to a
league like
you know costume party i'd probably want
to go as grace
with a cigar and all right would would
would my boy garen
of the second person um
yes yes actually i could see that
happening
hecarim pekram prefers to delete squishy
people and garen is a lot of things but
he ain't squishy